pour lui il sera jugé
j'ai trop mal j'ai trop mal surtout pour
cette dame je suis venue pour
premièrement pour m'excuser à cette dame
là et à sa famille
quand vous entendez des gens dire c'est
la faute des parents de l'éducation des
parents vous dites quoi moi j'ai pas de
doute que j'ai bien éduqué mes enfants
mais trois filles ont ils ont leur bac
et il a eu la même éducation et jusqu'à
jusqu'au jour où il a fait ça et jamais
de problème il y a pas de problème il y
avait des problèmes partir de 12 ans le
maîtrise mais à 14 ans elle te dit oui
il veut il veut c'est un petit enfant
dans un grand corps alors oui où il
répond qu'est-ce qu'on va qu'est-ce
qu'on va lui faire moi je suis
j'ai besoin moi je qu'est-ce que je fais
qu'est-ce que je fais ma maladie
il est malade ah ouais ma femme elle est
déjà il est malade mais là il est éteint